so what I want to do here is run over
the in continuity history of the
Infinity stones in Marvel Comics and the
reason why is because with Secret Wars
coming to an end in the next few weeks
the gauntlet will likely appear in the
all-new all-different marvel universe
and having a strong foundation of how
it's been used in the past will give us
a better idea of what to expect going
into the future so getting into this the
origins of the Infinity stones come by
way of a crossover story titled Avengers
ultra force and is actually up for
debate in terms of its canonicity which
is to say content that's considered to
be an official part of the Marvel
Universe but at the same time this
portion of the discussion will also
require us to delve into a bit of
comic-book history particularly the
comic bust of the 1990s
so comic book collecting has a
long-standing history in the industry
and has been done for several reasons
prior to the 1970s the collection of
comics was largely based on the
popularity of particular characters
stories and concepts including the
introductions of superheroes in 1938
Action Comics number one the true crime
genre with 1942 s crime does not pay
and the true love genre with 1947 s
young romance number one conversely
collecting during this time period was
only usually engaged in by hardcore fans
of the industry looking to simply hold
on to these various publications for the
sake of posterity or I'll sell them to
other collectors who are missing out
these particular issues however with the
advent of the comic buyer's guide in
1971 which began to provide a monetary
value for stories like the death of Gwen
Stacy and the soft relaunch of Superman
initiate number 233 under Julius
Schwartz both Marvel and DC as well as
fans began to recognize the fledgling
demand for comics that were only
available as collectors items accessible
through specialty shops that focused
heavily on limited publications and by
extension or worth large amounts of
money looking to capitalize on this
market in addition to the normal influx
of profit derived from the sales of
standard comics by the mid to late 1980s
both Marvel and DC alongside smaller
publishers began the process of creating
titles with unique features geared
towards collectors that drove a higher
premium in comparison to their
standard-issue counterparts as an
example the first comic to receive a
variant cover was the Man of Steel
number 1 by John Byrne the first in a
six-part limited series designed to read
how the origins of Superman
the post-crisis on Infinite Earths
continuity because it sold so well this
combined with the revolutionary idea of
DC rebooting its continuity led to fans
purchasing multiple copies of a single
issue or series in the hopes that it
would increase in value over time as a
byproduct with Marvel and DC unable to
differentiate between those who bought 5
copies and those who bought one and that
the information they received from
retailers was that they had simply sold
a high amount of copies by the mid-1990s
following the death of Superman and the
nightfall story arcs Marvel in DC as
well as other publishers have been
flooding the market with an excess of
specialty comics under the belief that
the comic industry was more popular than
it truly was now during this time a 1985
graduate of Denver University named
Scott Mitchell Rosenberg looked to break
into the comic book industry by creating
his own publishing house in the form of
Malibu comics for their own continuity
referred to as the ultraverse however
her Malibu fell short of both DC and
Marvel regarding their popularity and
success in 1992 during the rise of the
independent publishers following the
formation of image by Todd McFarlane Jim
Lee and Rob Liefeld Malibu gained a bit
more success with titles like the men in
black the Nightman
exiles and black September and so were
fans of the comic industry had nearly
bankrupted the market by creating the
illusion of high sales while Marvel DC
image and a handful of others survive in
near collapse Malibu didn't however
because some of Malibu styles were still
relatively popular in 1994 Marvel
acquired Malibu while creating a series
of stories which crushed the respective
universes over with one another and the
hopes of finding success from Malibu's
publications with the Marvel fan base
and so having said all of that
Avengers ultra force number one was
written by Glenn hurdling and drawn by
Angel Messina and MC Wyman centering on
the actions of a being named rune from
the ultraverse traveling to the
earth-616 dimension and stealing the
Infinity stones when they were taken to
his native dimension The Avengers were
assembled along with the heroes of the
ultraverse continuity for the purpose of
reacquiring the gems and returning them
to the rightful place now with the
conclusion of the event would see their
goal achieved during the story it was
revealed that prior to the creation of
all things in the Marvel Universe there
was a singular being named nemesis as
the only thing in existence at the time
Nemesis functioned with the desire to
create and build universes however for
reasons unexplained in this story
nemesis split itself into fragments
which became the infinity gems in
addition to this the crossover
established the existence of a seventh
gem called ego which functioned as a
sentience of Nemesis and a means to
control the others and with a purpose of
this was to create legitimacy for the
story and the development of Nemesis as
a villain it failed to attract fans and
at the story's conclusion the infinity
gems were returned to the Marvel
Universe and the ego gym was destroyed
however by combining the information
provided here with the 1990s story
Pharaoh's quest we can piece together
the origins of the gems in stating that
when nemesis had split itself into the
gems due to the feeling of loneliness
its actions created the multiverse as we
know it in Marvel Comics including a set
of gems and each continuity in now gem
in a 1972 with the first chronological
appearance of the gems in Marvel
premiere number one this story served to
do a purpose by not only introducing the
gems but also providing Adam warlock
with his first story outside of the
publication's of existing characters
winding the clock back to 1967 with
Fantastic Four issue 66 and 67 Adam
warlock originally appeared as an
experiment at the hands of a group
called The Enclave
which was composed of several genius
level scientists bent on world
domination however within this story the
Fantastic Four had made their way into
the base of the Enclave discovered Adams
cocoon and after he emerged a short
battle ensued at which point he simply
took off with no explanation of where he
went now because the Fantastic Four
existed as Marvel's top-selling comic
next to spider-man during the late 1960s
the title served to expose readers to
new characters and teams but also
maintain the element
real-world stories were the appearance
of Adam warlock sparked interest in fans
and that there wasn't so much of a high
demand for his return as there was a
passing curiosity Adam appeared for a
second time two years later and Thor
issues 165 and 167 in 1969 during this
story
the popularity of warlock reach greater
heights and that he was demonstrated as
capable of going toe-to-toe with Thor in
his effort to take SIF as a bride well
the story eventually saw Adams defeat by
way of entering his cocoon form in order
to recover from his injuries after
battling Thor of being with strength of
that magnitude Joe fans to demand
further adventures involving Adam and so
following this because these early
appearances of warlock were designed to
test fan curiosity rather than flesh out
his character with Marvel premiere
introduced to operate as a test bed for
new characters who didn't warrant a
title issue number one saw a wholesale
revamp of Adam under the control of
writer Roy Thomas and artists Gil Kane
where he had previously been depicted as
a being looking to find his place in the
pantheon of life within the Marvel
Universe and Marvel premiere Roy Thomas
reintroduced warlock as a christ-like
figure which began the trend of him
appearing during times of extreme need
within the Marvel Universe toll from the
perspective of an alien named sphincter
whose history remains ambiguous but who
operated as an agent of the beyonders
the history of Adam regarding his
original creation discovery by the
Fantastic Four and Escape is retold in
addition to this his battle with Thor is
recounted in terms of his attempt to
acquire sit as a bride however what were
also told is that following his escape
from Thor and returned to the depths of
space
he was eventually discovered and
captured by the High Evolutionary nat
aside chat for a second the High
Evolutionary was formerly a man named
Herbert Wyndham who had obtained the key
to manipulating the human genome by way
of the Inhumans and in doing so began
the process of creating artificial life
and enhancing his own genetic structure
allowing for powers on par with Galactus
taking to the outlying Serbian territory
of transia in the wondercore mountains
the ultimate project of the High
Evolutionary came to fruition with its
development of counter-earth another
version of the earth on the opposite
side of the Sun that was allowed to
evolve in the same fashion as our own
however over the course of its
development one of the high
evolutionary's creations called man
beast had seized control of the planet
and made it his own and during the
initial battle between man beasts in the
High Evolutionary Adam warlock watched
on from his cocoon
after realizing that the death of the
High Evolutionary would come with the
full-on invasion of Earth from the
counter-earth inhabitants warlock chose
to intervene by emerging from its cocoon
and battling man beast where man bees
and his forces were successfully able to
retreat in an effort to wipe out his
forces and continue to allow
counter-earth to function normally at a
Morlock was tasked with facing off
against man beast and provided the soul
gym to achieve his goal now in terms of
its history were not actually provided
any information on the time between the
dispersion of the gyms following the
suicide of nemesis and this particular
story instead the High Evolutionary
simply has the gym and gives it to
warlock following this for Adam was
successful in defeating man beast and
restoring the normal evolution of
counter-earth and its inhabitants the
soul gem became an intricate part of his
character's history by allowing Adam to
develop a home of sorts within soul
world a pocket universe house within the
soul gym inhabited by the various souls
that is consumed over the course of its
existence now regarding the other gems
of the mind power time-space in reality
these artifacts first appeared during
the two-part story Deathwatch covered in
Avengers annual number seven and Marvel
two and one annual number two much like
the Infinity Gauntlet event the story
focus on Thanos his attempt to gain the
affections of mistress death by killing
as much life as possible what we're told
is that Thanos had set about his goal by
coming over information across thousands
of worlds eventually stumbling across a
scroll that described the infinity gems
and the power they possessed something
to note here is that unlike the Thanos
quest which led to the Infinity Gauntlet
and provided a detailed account of how
Thanos was able to acquire the gems a
second time in this story were given a
basic overview of his journey in
addition to this prior to the Infinity
Gauntlet event the Infinity stones were
actually referred to as the soul gems
but for the sake of this discussion
we're just kind of calling them Infinity
stones or infinity gems but what we're
told is if Thanos had first traveled the
cosmos capturing the gems from the
stranger one of the cosmic entities of
the Marvel Universe a prison satellite
of an unknown world a cavern on the
planet Deneb for a monster named Z on
board and the moon of Earth however his
journey was effectively incomplete and
that because Adam warlock possessed the
soul gem and would not give it up due to
his connection to it as well as the
power that it possessed
Thanos instead
the energies from the gym and along with
the others created one massive stone
with the goal destroying all the stars
in the universe
now without a feet advisor combined
efforts of the Avengers quasar Adam
warlock Gamora and moon dragon the
daughter of Drax a destroyer
during the battle Ironman had destroyed
the massive stone which in turn
dispersed the infinity gems throughout
the cosmos for another time
now following this the infinity gems
returned for a third time during a
storyline taking place and Silver Surfer
vol three issues 9 10 15 16 17 and 18 as
well as Silver Surfer annual number one
an issues nine and ten
we're told that somewhere between the
defeat of Thanos in the start of this
arc the elders of the universe who were
the last few many members of the
respective races had banded together for
the purpose of syncing the stones to a
machine and stripping Galactus of his
power with a combined efforts of the
Fantastic Four eternity mistress death
and the Celestials were successful in
defeating the elders at the end of issue
number 10 the gems were cast into a
gravity well and Galactus absorbed the
elders into himself with the intention
of draining their life energy killing
them in the process however the story
was followed up and Silver Surfer annual
number one as well as issues 15 and 16
when it was revealed that the elders had
survived the reason for this was that
during the 1982 story contest of
Champions which functioned as Marvel's
first major crossover a game was held
between Grand Master of the elders of
the universe and mistress death with the
Grandmaster looking to return the
collector to life after having
previously died where the game found the
Grandmaster successful albeit at the
cost of his own life and that he had to
take the collectors place in the realm
of the dead grandmasters actions were
revealed to be a ruse allowing him to
temporarily steal mistress death powers
making himself and the other elders
immortal as a result and Silver Surfer
annual number 1 the elders began the
process of consuming Galactus energies
during which time he had sent his Herald
Nova to enlist the aid of silver surfer
Susan storm and Reed Richards according
to the story as it was written where the
infinity gems had been thrown into a
black hole because Galactus was unable
to expel the elders silver surfer Susan
and Reed entered the black hole for the
purpose of bringing the gems back and
restoring Galactus with issue number 15
and finding the group successful issue
number 16 revealed that the actions of
the elders and bringing the gems
together there
salt on Galactus as well as surfer Reed
and Sue traveling into the black hole
for all the meccans of the in-betweener
the cosmic entity representing the
balance in reality who look to destroy
Galactus following this Susan and Reed
were able to make contact with the
cosmic entities master order and Lord
chaos who had created the in-betweener
during which time the entities remove
the elders from Galactus after which
they combine the in-betweener to a
prison at the nexus point of all
realities now jumping to the 1990 story
Thanos quest by jim Starlin which led
directly into the Infinity Gauntlet it
was revealed that after the defeat of
the in-betweener he along with the
elders of the universe had each taken
possession of an infinity stone and
looking to assemble the gauntlet as a
means to control all of reality then the
universe to his will and make mr. su
death love him Thanos traveled the
farthest reaches of existence defeating
each of the elders and tricking the
in-betweener into handing his Jim over
after which the Infinity Gauntlet event
took place
now following Infinity Gauntlet which
ended with Adam warlock taking
possession of the gauntlet and ending
the conflict he was immediately brought
before the Living Tribunal by eternity
and the rest of the cosmic entities who
looked at the Living Tribunal to destroy
the gauntlet as well as the gems
refusing to do so the Living Tribunal
instead disable the gems from working
together ordered atom to disassemble the
gauntlet and spread the gems among those
individuals who would hold them but
never use them to this end the Infinity
watch was formed composed of atom with
the sole Jim Gamora with the time Jim
Drax a destroyer with the power Jim hip
the troll of the space Jim lewd record
with the mind Jim and the reality Jim
going to an individual known only to
Adam and so with the infinity war
storyline it was revealed that at the
end of the Infinity Gauntlet event when
Adam had taken control of the gauntlet
he had subconsciously split himself into
two individuals one of pure evil and one
appear good as a story that focused on
the evil portion of Adam taking the form
of his alter ego The Magus he was
revealed that Magus to travel the
multiverse acquiring five cosmic cubes
under the hopes that the Infinity watch
would band together against the common
threat proving itself to be true Magus
defeated each member of the watch with
Thanos revealed to be in possession of
the reality Jim assembling the Infinity
Gauntlet for second time maggots was
defeated when it was revealed that Alice
had actually given him a false reality
Jim making the gauntlet and complete
leading to Magus being defeated and
confined to the soultion by warlock
but unable to be seen or heard by any of
its denizens from here as far as I know
the infinity gems are not seen or heard
from again in Marvel until 2004 during
the 12 part Thanos miniseries in issue
number 6 it was revealed the Galactus
had collected the Infinity stones for
the purpose of ending his desire to
consume planets but in the process
Unleashed at being of psychic energy
known as the hunger who is an entity
that traveled through the multiverse
consuming entire realities revealing
that the plan of hunger was to use
Galactus as a means to open a
dimensional doorway allowing for its
entrance into the earth-616 continuity
Thanos intervened assembled the gems
destroyed hunger after which the gems
were cashed throughout the universe safe
for the soul stone which was then
restored to Adam warlock who had been in
a comatose state since the end of
infinity war now following this the
power gem had supposedly fallen into the
hands of she-hulk during issues 9 10 and
11 of her solo series but I can't
actually find any information on this
line of comics so I won't swear to it
but what we do know is that after the
incident with Thanos during the five
issue New Avengers branch off series
titled Illuminati which focus on the
group's actions over the course of their
existence under Brian Michael Bendis it
was established in issue number two that
Reed Richards had come into possession
of the gauntlet and successfully
attained three of the six gems in
addition to this it was recognized that
where previously the gems were believed
to simply exist as items of extreme
power that in truth they had actually
communicated with each other allowing
for the possessor of one gem to acquire
the remaining five by leading the
wielder to their locations however
because the Infinity Gauntlet have been
established that no one is immune to the
overwhelming power that comes with the
gauntlet when it was fully assembled by
the Illuminati
Reed was visited by watching The Watcher
stating that his intention was to use
the godless full power to destroy the
gauntlet itself and ensure the safety of
the universe when his efforts proved to
be unsuccessful he acquiesced to The
Watcher agreeing to remove the gauntlet
and handing the gems over to each member
of the Illuminati for safekeeping
now something I want to point out here
is that Reed himself was not immune to
the influence of the gauntlets power and
it actually expressed a desire to keep
it for himself
however the indication here by Charles
Xavier at the end of the story was that
he effectively forced Reed to give up
the gauntlet by manipulating his mind
but regardless prior to the collapse of
the multiverse and drained
the Hickman's run of Avengers and New
Avengers the gyms reappeared for the
final time before Secret Wars when the
earth-616 continuity was met with his
first and curse of earth and potential
destruction during the events of New
Avengers vol 3 issue number 3 the
gauntlet was reassembled by Captain
America and the Illuminati who attended
to use it to stop the incursion during
which time the stones were destroyed
with the exception of the time gem which
began to send Captain America forward
through time where he met Franklin
Richards in the future learning that the
end of all things could not be stopped
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and let me
know how you guys feel down in the
comments section about these artifact
kind of videos where we literally just
run over the chronological history of
different artifacts in Marvel Comics and
I will catch you guys later peace